offener judenhasser auf den straßen der
hauptstadt das konnten wir erleben in
der vergangenen woche und auch heute
hätte es wieder soweit kommen können
lassen die bilder aus der letzten runde
letzten woche rund 600 menschen ziehen
dort durch die hauptstadt verbreiten
antisemitische hetze ja und heute also
dieser sogenannten al kuds tag das ist
immer noch mal ein anlass um diesen
judenhass hier auf die straße zu tragen
so war es in all den vergangenen jahren
immer wieder demonstrationen an diesem
sogenannten al kuds tag eben vor allen
dingen hier in der hauptstadt hier in
berlin und jetzt ist diese kundgebung
gerade von der berliner polizei verboten
worden also dass jetzt ein erster
schritt um das alles zu unterbieten
unterbinden um diese leute zu hause zu
lassen und ihnen nicht dieses forum
diese bühne zu bieten für ihren anti
israel und ihren judenhass der
einsatzleiter der berliner polizei
rechnet allerdings hören wir gerade
damit dass trotzdem ganz viele dieser
männer und frauen auf die straße gehen
und gegen israel hetzen trotz verbots
darüber wollen wir jetzt sprechen mit
unserem bild reporter peter wilke der
all das in den vergangenen tagen erlebt
hat diesen judenhass auf unseren straßen
und mit dem wissenschaftler ahmad
mansour islamwissenschaftler der uns
zugeschaltet ist euch beiden herzlich
willkommen bei bild live peter einmal
ganz schnell die demo ist erst mal
abgesagt und trotzdem rechnet die
polizei mit ganz vielen die dann
trotzdem kommen
genau es gab ja heute morgen ein
pressebriefing bei der polizei hier in
kreuzberg wo eben darüber gesprochen
wurde wie die polizei sich auf diesen
einsatz vorbereitet dort wurde zuerst
einmal erklärt warum diese angekündigte
demonstration von seiten der polizei
verboten wurde weil man eben damit
rechnet dass es auch heute wieder dort
zu antisemitismus kommen würde das ist
auch dort zu gewalttätigen kommen wird
und dass auch dort gewalt ausgeübt wird
gegen anderen menschen gegen auch und
pressevertretern deswegen wurde diese
kundgebung von der polizei verboten aber
das verwaltungsgericht prüft diese
entscheidung noch das verwaltungsgericht
berlin und wird in den nächsten stunden
sich dazu äußern und das könnte sein
dass dieses verbot dann doch gekippt
wird also da gibt es sozusagen zwei
szenarien vollsten nachmittag entweder
bleibt das verbot bestehen dann wird die
polizei dort vor ort sein und alle
teilnehmer die hinkommen und trotzdem
demonstrieren direkt von dem ort
entfernt
zur not eben mit gewalt oder das dem das
verbot wird gekippt dann wird die
polizei auch vor ort sein mit 600 bis
700 kräften was enorm viel ist im
vergleich zur letzten woche letzten
woche war die guten zeit nur mit 150
kräften vor ort und damit auch sehr
unterfordert hat das heute auch ein
bisschen eingestanden dass das letzte
woche nicht alles rund gelaufen ist und
wird dann eben diese demonstration
schützen und begleiten wenn sie denn
stattfindet hat aber auch klar
kommuniziert dass sie genau hinhören
werden was dort gesagt wird wenn es zu
antisemitischen äußerungen kommen wird
wird das direkt unterbunden werden
personen festgenommen da sind unter
anderem fünf dolmetscher im einsatz aber
auch das lka die spezialisten vom
staatsschutz werden heute fort sind
wenn man so sehr wir alle waren tief
schockiert als wir diesen offenen
judenhass in der hauptstadt in der
vergangenen woche gesehen haben und er
hat gleichzeitig auch die strukturen des
antisemitismus hier in deutschland
entblößt viele waren überrascht wie tief
diese strukturen gehen und in welche
bereiche sie herein reichen hat sie das
auch überrascht nein ich bin immer
wieder überrascht warum wir überrascht
leer gehen ich meine ich lebe seit 18
jahren in deutschland und ich habe es
schon mindestens zehn debatten gemacht
ich erinnere nur an die mai letzten
jahres alles auch überall in deutschland
so antisemitische parolen gekommen ist
diese art von antisemitismus
getarnt als anti israel oder israel
kritik ist etwas was vor allem unter
flüchtlinge und muslimischer
jugendlicher weit verbreitet eine
reflektion eine möglichkeit diesen
konflikt etwas differenzierter zu sehen
ist nicht vorhanden bei vielen diese
menschen auf die idee die auch die demos
waren und deshalb bin ich nicht
überrascht ich bin
nur überrascht dass wir die diskussion
immer wieder bei null anfangen dass
unsere politiker immer noch keine
konzepte geliefert haben das reicht
nicht nur mit polizei zu reagieren
sondern wir müssen schauen wie wir diese
menschen für unsere grundrechte gewinnen
wenn sie in neukölln mal durch die
straßen gehen oder hier in kreuzberg
also direkt hinter unserem bild live
studio finden sie da auf den straßen
eine mehrheit für den staat israel oder
auch in den schulen hier in kreuzberg in
neukölln also erstmal damit ich nicht
für allgemeiner ich kenne viele menschen
arabisch stämmig palästinensische
stimmig aber auch muslime in der zweite
und dritte generation die in deutschland
angekommen sind die natürlich für das
existenzrecht israel stehen die sogar in
israel waren und überhaupt keine
antisemitische einstellungen mehr teilen
unter flüchtlinge die wo anders
sozialisiert sind ist diese mehrheit
nicht vorhanden das heißt die mehrheit
davon distanziert sich von israel oder
hat eine amtliche klar antisemitische
einstellungen mitgebracht unter
jugendlicher im allgemeinen vor allem in
zeiten von tik tok und instagram ist der
sicht auf dieser konflikt sehr
emotionalisiert diese menschen sehen nur
eine seite sie betrachten die israel als
aggressor und die palästinenser als
opfer und da es sehr sehr schwierig
unter solche unreflektierter
jugendlicher menschen zu finden die für
das existenzrecht israel sehr deutlich
und vor allem in der öffentlichkeit
stehen hermann so man hat auch den
eindruck dass es der politik oft schwer
fällt ganz genau oder auch die täter zu
benennen sich mit dem fakt
auseinanderzusetzen dass es eben eine
gewaltbereite muslime gibt sie ihrem
judenhass auf der straße in der
hauptstadt wie wir vergangenes
wochenende gesehen haben ganz ganz
deutlich laut machen haben sie das
gefühl wir erhalten da genug den finger
in die wunde wir beobachten ist genug
sprechen auch offen aus was dort
passiert oder findet er zum großen teil
auch noch eine gewisse schönrednerei
statt ich finde eine verharmlosung und
relativierung wir haben in unsere
diskurs kultur ein problem bestimmte
themen deutlich zu benennen aus angst
die falschen zu
bestätigen oder als rassisten oder als
islamfeindlich zu gelten solange wir
aber diese probleme nicht benennen
natürlich differenziert sachlich ohne
alle zur allgemeinen in einen topf zu
werfen werden die nicht in der lage
wirklich lösungen zu finden lösungen
bedeutet auch zu schauen was hat das mit
religion zu tun was hat das mit
bestimmten islamverständnis zu tun mit
integration zu tun das sind ja
paradebeispiele für gescheiterter
integration und wenn unsere politiker
nicht die vorbild nehmen und dass da
ganz deutlich benennen dann bin ich
nicht wirklich optimistisch dass wir in
der lage sind lösungen für diese
probleme zu haben sagt ahmed mansur
vielen herzlichen dank ihnen für ihre
analyse und auch danke an peter wilke
unseren reporter der hier auf den
straßen in der hauptstadt trotz des demo
verbots die situation weiter im auge
behält